[Music]
to be honest i feel a bit numb
but somewhere deep inside i feel really
thankful and i know the excitement is
going to follow soon
i feel this is a really big moment for
me i feel really fulfilled it's been a
lot of months coming a lot of work done
in the background so i'm really happy i
really am yeah
it's
been 11 years since my first public
speaking contest ever and it's been a
ton of failures on the way and a few
times when i thought i'd just give up
and never do it again
the key was always consistency and i'm
really thankful that i had people along
the way to remind me that i had an
obligation to myself and to many people
to try again
i think with trying again and being
consistent you start to learn more
things from the competition itself and
so the contest it becomes less of this
game of
propping up your ego and more of an
attempt to learn something and see what
other people are doing to better
themselves in a contest public speaking
is very subjective you are working with
people's emotions and to some extent
people can tell when you're acting and
it doesn't really connect it doesn't
land well public speaking is that one
shall i say game where you really need
to bring your truest self so the tip i
would give is what is your story what is
that one thing you believe in so much
that you really want the world to hear
because guess what that's your speech
[Music]
you